since the start of the pandemic asian
americans across the nation have been
the target of a sharp
increase in harassment and hate crimes
president biden issued a sharp
condemnation of the attacks on thursday
during his first
prime time address to the nation wii xi
jiang reports
president biden's message about the
attacks on asian americans
was clear it's wrong it's un-american
and it
must stop the advocacy groups stop
aapi hate has recorded more than 3
thousand incidents since the start of
the pandemic
on thursday 75 year old pog hoe died in
oakland california
after he was knocked to the ground
during a robbery
the city's police department said the
suspect has a history of
victimizing elderly asian people vicious
hate crimes against asian americans
who've been attacked harassed blamed and
scapegoated
the president has also condemned the
racist rhetoric
used to describe the virus a stark
contrast
from his predecessor kung flu
the china virus i do believe that kind
of rhetoric
really helped fuel a lot more
crimes and attacks yunhan zhang
experienced it himself
when a man shouting slurs pepper sprayed
zhang in november
at his tea shop in washington d.c zhang
is hopeful that president biden's
message will prevent
others from getting hurt at least now we
have our first step
then with more efforts we can maybe
make a real difference lawmakers have
introduced new legislation to deal with
this surge in crimes including
one measure that would direct the
attorney general to create a new
position
at the justice department to handle all
of the cases
next week there is a hearing scheduled
in the house judiciary committee
on all the violence and discrimination
for cbs this morning saturday
weeja jang washington d.c
[Music]
nice to see that noted in the address
this week because the number of
times this has happened has just become
outrageous
it's harder and harder to watch really
is